we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
do you guys ever fear the end of the
world all the time
what really you i don't take you of that
type well
i'm not necessarily afraid of it but i'm
more thinking of it as a writer where
i'm like
okay what could that be and like how can
i write towards that and how close are
we yeah for sure
so you're thinking more from an artistic
point of view not from like
a real life point of view well uh end of
the world
meaning what right like so the end of
our world like the romans probably
thought it was the end of the world when
their empire was collapsing but it
wasn't the other one at the end of
america
right exactly so exactly right so it's
all relative to whatever
society you're in can i picture like
meteor earth yeah
that's my picture oh let's go with the
ladder there yeah
the the whole meteor hitting the the
earth and stuff like uh
armageddon how long do i got to live i
thought about it and for me i'm
like if it's my time to go this one time
though it is
all in it together yeah we're all going
out together
instead of like my our nation i think my
man here's going to survive though
because he just stocked up on beans i
know that for a fact
i got a lot of beans he's got like a
year supply i think he's gonna be good
how many beans though
give me can count i just ate my last one
what the [ __ ] i knew it there's always i
don't have a stockpile i'll stick it up
for you
okay there's always details with
whatever he says we gotta uncover those
details i'm sorry you've known them
longer than me
yeah you'll catch up you consider
lentils as beans because i got a bag of
that
legumes how long have i has it been
sitting there
um six months have you checked if
there's any holes in the back
because we've had some stuff we've had
some stockpiles and then we found out
some rats got to them
no no what was it what did it get to do
he makes a bunch of [ __ ] up don't just
take
something it opened something like oh
[ __ ] half of it's gone
oh [ __ ] you gotta worry about your
stockpiles and foods actually go bad
there's expiration dates on them they
just bloated they go well
but they're called what non-perishables
so i was like
you never had a hoarder grandma huh huh
oh silly son of a [ __ ]
yeah no my i know that for a fact
because my grandparents had canned
peaches that we found that were
insane did you open it did you eat it
like green inside or something yeah it
was no well it was just powder basically
it was nuts wow they didn't do a good
job preserving it i was like 40 years
old
or something yeah it was literally from
the 70s
you should have made a video about that
yeah i didn't even think too at the time
yeah could have gone
tick-tock grandma's 40-year-old can of
power and then you should have ate it
i think there's a guy that eats old mr
ease oh yeah how old wait how are you
what's that they're like
yeah meal ready to eat like these milk
food like current ones too from
different countries like he'll eat stuff
from like korea or whatever
which country does it best korea one was
pretty cool looking like it was like it
was like curry rice or something
but then um our military what he's
tasked with he had a uh
old one from like the vietnam war or
something like that god
and he pulled out the whole like rations
and food
and then they gave him a pack of
cigarettes and he smoked that too
so there was something crazy yeah like i
guess they used to give cigarettes out
like it was it was
a part of the meal well because the
doctors used to recommend them yes
oh yeah you're in the battlefield you're
wounded have a cig
there's like i love lucy and there's
like i love lucy episodes where she's
clearly pregnant she was really pregnant
when she was on the show
and then like ricky her husband's like
just smoking away like in the scene i'm
like
[ __ ] didn't know about secondhand smoke
back then yeah [ __ ] it damn
well back to the end of the world uh
right just like in armageddon uh
a lot of scientists are now realizing
that there is a gigantic
uh meteor headed towards earth really
might make contact with on election day
yes
no no no no no no no no no are you sure
the day before the day before
day before yeah we will never find out i
think neil degrassi talked about it
right why is it
no no actually why do you tell us now
well no there's one that's gonna hit
before like just day before election day
of this year but the size of the city i
didn't hear about that one then i don't
know the size of a city bustle so it's
not a cataclysmic one oh i see this one
damn what if it just comes here i don't
want that no it's not statistically
impossible but yeah
well the one i'm talking about it's been
nicknamed after the egyptian god of
chaos
called apophis oh what a dope name yes
it is a titan it's a powerful name
hey apophis that should have been tyka's
middle name
what if that name back then was like
john
it ain't anymore joe it just sounds cool
now but back then it was like that's
your
god of chaos so it's like someone named
christian or something
pretty sick but anyway so this meteor
is or asteroid i guess what's the
difference between an asteroid meteor i
don't even know
asteroids it's a thousand miles
long that's how big it is yes how big is
a thousand miles like america like
this
[Laughter]
that's for sure so thousands of
thousands the thousand miles in width
yes
so it's like two distinct like from here
to vegas times two
that's all right wait wait how how far
is vegas from here five hundred four
five or something
this is like armageddon that would be
more than it like we just need a mile
wide and we're [ __ ]
that's like the moon deep impact [ __ ]
but if it's a mile long and it's coming
we could probably blast it with
something right dude a thousand mile
long
like you're talking about fragments that
would all be miles
wide oh true a thousand miles that's
like bigger than a lot of countries
wait when's it hitting am i going to die
first of all age because i don't give a
[ __ ] about the young kids well it
depends on how
what old age is so they're guesstimating
2068. heading towards earth
we'll be alive we'll handle it we'll
handle it
i'm 37 now 20. has kids that are 30 now
they will be able to get there by in
time and we'll be fine right
if nothing bruce willis sends his kids
rumor willis that's right yes
i need to buy a house with the basement
that's not needed
baseband gonna help dude holy [ __ ] dude
you know what you gotta do
spacex oh go out
okay while it hits the earth and eat
popcorn while you watch it
and then you gotta find oh and occupy
one of those other earthquakes it's a
big fight to get on that
spaceship just don't tell anybody keep
it can you just keep it a secret to
start
how about right now we start
manufacturing many pillows
many many many many many many soften the
impact right yeah no no
we take them up and put them on all the
edges
like you know with zip ties or whatever
what if we create a big like slingshot
right because with math we can we can
see like the projection doesn't sound
realistic
oh yeah so we catch it then yeah and
then we [ __ ] you and it goes back out
you know what i mean
karma engine that through on mars and
and in the moon
and just and it hits the moon and then
it [ __ ] destroys the earth anyway
we're like ah [ __ ]
you guys are so stupid all right there's
seven billion people right
yeah all we need is we catch it is we
need to stand outside
and blow up words oh that's sick
yeah we could play people you weren't so
you were on such a good track
with seven billion breaths going up okay
it's gonna knock it back like seven
billion people we start making guns now
we all fire at the same time in the sky
because we all love to do that anyway
we're american yeah yeah i think we
could take that thing out but we gotta
shoot in the same direction because if
we're all around we're always going to
shoot like this
oh bro how are the people down here
going to shoot over here what i got it
we know when it's coming yeah we know
where it's going to hit yeah
we just all meet there so we all die
together wait
no we all meet there suicide pact
suicide oh we all meet there we
concentrate our
shooting range it's a flash mob oh yeah
and then we all get together and then we
shoot upwards
okay you forgot that part first gotcha
how about we do that but the opposite
instead of meeting there
we go away look it's going to [ __ ] up
the earth we have to
wait why is everyone so scared of global
warming now exactly because uh
[Laughter]
i'm over it now are they all right let's
figure this one out
so to give you guys a little bit of
relief um
that's just what they're uh they think
the trajectory is as of right now
a lot can happen in 40 years something
else could come and hit it
you know you never know gravitational
pull can
can change over time yeah uh and drip
start drifting away
um and also they actually back in 2004
they discovered another
um apophis they actually called this
other asteroid apocalypse as well
and it wasn't a swing past earth by 2029
and at one point they thought this 2029
asteroid was going to collide with earth
as well
but now now with that it's you know much
closer that time they realize the
trajectory of this asteroid
is gonna swing by like just barely you
know like we
and well you know what they said that we
would actually be able to see it fly by
with the to the naked eye yes we could
look up and actually see this asteroid
fly
those nerds can't calculate [ __ ] can
they because they got it wrong before
they're probably gonna get this one
wrong true yeah it's probably not gonna
be probably gonna hit us for sure
i'll be 82 years old i don't give a [ __ ]
in fact i think we should preserve all
asteroids
is what i think preserve them i'd be
okay with dying at that time yeah i'm
giving five
i don't want anyone else to upstage me
anyway
oh right so it just ends your little
filling line yeah
and then you end it there and you don't
let the younger generation
upstage you dude imagine we're the last
generation
that sucks oh that sucks
we're trash we're trash speak for
yourself trash
i'm gold we made a lot of cool
advancements
yeah i say we because i'm lazy but i
mean elon's sick right
we the he we the human race yeah yeah
elon's done so much that thank god go do
it buddy go do it i'm
cool with being a cheerleader like i
love that
humans can achieve so much and i can be
a part of that
without lifting a finger and say humans
are cool would you think by 2068 by 2060
do you think we'll be already
up in outer space and like would have
like a new home
we'll be back in mars and within three
years from now i think
we'll be going uh we'll be going to the
moon with again within three years from
now do you think the colonization of
other planets is already going to happen
in our lifetime yes it has to happen in
our lifetime so we're going to be
we're going to be planting fluid we can
just kind of up and go anywhere and
avoid
being destroyed we'll also terraform
mars to make mars more earth-like
which is going to be sick and then we'll
have two earths hello
that's what what planet right now is can
we uh
mars mars is the one because i thought
there were like 20 something other ones
that they just discovered
take like light years to get there we
don't have that technology
they're not in the milky way we'd have
to sacrifice generations of people to
get there when did you guys get so smart
what the [ __ ]
i watched interstellar and i learned
that you can go through black holes and
stuff
i'll watch a youtube ad yeah or a
youtube ad yeah
okay what so what so martial well
terraform mars right we'll change the
conditions on mars using a bunch of
different uh like
planting techniques and different
atmospheric uh
things that we can change right we can
actually do that we do it all the time
in greenhouses and [ __ ]
so that's when [ __ ] gets interesting
because we make mars more earth-like
and hopefully introduce water there but
there's probably already water there
and so we'll be able to live on mars
like we do now with oxygen and
everything
like that we have here isn't the big
problem like the pressure
on is that what they're trying to solve
it's what's
it's also the temperature right so the
the that we would have to
they have mars has no atmosphere sure
whatsoever like it's it's no atmospheric
pressure you have to build it with the
terror for me
you would have to yeah you'd have to
hopefully get that going yeah
something really weird and gross happens
to human bodies when they're in a
space of zero pressure what happens
don't remember but it's weird
so they have to figure that out far
backwards i fart backwards every time i
hold it in my fart i know you're talking
about it's like it gets all like um
you have nothing to hold your bones
together there's no like gravity right
right like i was assuming like we're in
a space
suit and yeah yeah i think everything
just falls off yeah i think your bones
like
don't do so well in that environment
yeah you're right sure that's what
they're always exercising too yeah
[Music]
you